Kaum etwas in Deutschland ist so erfolgreich
wie die Automobilindustrie:
wichtigster Arbeitgeber, größter Steuerzahler,
Exportweltmeister, made in Germany.
Doch plötzlich läuft nicht mehr alles rund.
Alle Welt fragt sich: Sind die denn verrückt
geworden?
Mad in Germany?
Das kann doch nicht sein,
dass der Bürger hier im Regen steht.
Und dann sich ein neues Auto kaufen soll
für 30.000.
Also, wo stehen wir eigentlich hier?
[Es] kann ja nicht jeder/jede alle zwei Jahre
ein Auto kaufen.
Ach, was für ein Traum für die Autohersteller!
Jeder Bürger alle zwei Jahre ein neues Auto –
was für ein Geschäft!
Aber eigentlich müssten sie erst mal jene
Diesel-Autos nachrüsten,
die sie bis vor kurzem noch verkauft haben,
die aber zu viel Stickstoffdioxid ausstoßen.
Auch das macht hier viele verrückt.
Schon schließen sich hustende Anwohner
stark befahrener Straßen zusammen.
Und ein Gericht nach dem anderen verhängt
Fahrverbote.
Davon sind sehr viele Autofahrer betroffen.
200.000 allein in Berlin. 100.000 in Köln.
Und, und, und.
Schon ab nächstem Jahr
dürfen sie viele Strecken nicht mehr fahren.
Völlig ungeklärt:
Wer und wie soll kontrolliert werden?
So viele Polizisten gibt es gar nicht in
Deutschland,
eine automatische Kennzeichenerfassung will
aber auch keiner.
Und wie verlässlich sind eigentlich die
Messdaten?
In der einen Stadt wird direkt neben der
Straße gemessen,
in der nächsten Stadt zehn Meter entfernt.
In der einen Stadt messen sie in vier Meter
Höhe, in der anderen in Bodennähe.
Dieses Video wurde schon drei Millionen Mal
geklickt:
Ich drück‘ ‘n Blinker von meinem Stinker,
bevor ich mich schon wieder nur aufreg‘.
Ihr tut mich hassen, blöde Öko-Affen, doch
ich geb‘ meinen, meinen Flitzer nicht zurück.
Zurückgeben liegt gerade voll im Trend.
Auf Deutschlands Schrottplätzen ist kaum
noch Platz.
Die Autohersteller zahlen für die
Verschrottung alter Diesel
Prämien bis zu 5000 Euro, wenn sich der
Fahrer ein neues Auto kauft.
Das tut ganz schön weh, weil so ein Fahrzeug
... Der hat 47.000 Kilometer runter,
der ist so sauber, natürlich,
der könnte noch einige Jahre auf der Straße
fahren.
Mein Wagen fährt Diesel,
bis in alle Ewigkeit.